the year is 1924. in a fog-draped Gorge
near the foothills of Mount St Helens a
group of gold prospectors encounter a
pack of ape men near their remote cabin
fearing for their lives one of the group
fredbeck fires his rifle at the Beast
wounding one and scaring them off for
the moment
later that night the Prospectors waked
their cabin under attack having returned
under cover of Darkness the Beast hurled
stones and pounded on the walls for
hours finally retreating after Sunrise
the terrified Prospectors fled back to
their Oregon town and told their tale to
all who would hear it earning the remote
spot the name ape Canyon after the
incident this was not the first story of
an encounter with massive bipedal Harry
ape-like beasts in North America other
stories go back centuries across the
continent but why does the legend of
this Cryptid endure and what can
Sasquatch teach us about the anxieties
we may have about the wild world around
us and our place in it
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
Sasquatch is often described as a large
bipedal primate or dark hair covered
humanoid varying in height from 6 to 15
feet with broad muscular shoulders
little or no neck in long ape-like arms
many sightings report that the creature
appears more human than Beast While
others report glowing eyes or salivating
bloodthirsty mom
our modern cultural Consciousness
positions this mysterious creature
solidly in the 20th century placed there
by the mass media who often fail to
report that this monster origin stories
go back hundreds if not thousands of
years and pre-date European colonization
of the new world the Chehalis people are
a First Nations Community located in the
Frazier Valley of British Columbia
Canada they tell of a shape-shifting
forest protector known as sasquettes
Sasquatch is an anglicized version of
saucecuts which translates roughly to
hairy man in the hakome language the
Chehalis people Revere sauce cats as a
wild and Elusive guardian of the
Wilderness who possesses supernatural
abilities to protect and guide those who
respect and honor their natural
environment in their culture sasquets is
the very embodiment of the benevolent
Spirit of the forest
a little over a thousand miles to the
south at the Thule River Indian
reservation in California ancient Rock
paintings or pictographs depict a small
group of Sasquatch known as the family
it is believed to be one of the earliest
recorded appearances of the monster
the largest creature in the pictograph
is thought to represent a paternal
figure and is accompanied by a mother
and child Lexus cats this hairy man
figure embodies traditional human
characteristics like bipedal walking
humanoid physiology and Community
Building while also evoking the more
elusive wildness of nature in some
Legends they even had a hand in
Humanity's creation but not all origin
stories from North American indigenous
folklore depicts Sasquatch as a
benevolent Guardian some feature the
being as a darker lurking malevolent
Force the Lummi people of coastal
Washington State tell of massive bipedal
stalkers with furry white faces who
carry misbehaving children off into the
night several Iroquoian and Algonquian
language peoples share stories of
cannibalistic humanoid Giants known as
stone giants Stone men or the stone clad
depending on the story these forest
dwellers cover themselves with stones or
rub sand on their bodies to callous
their skin in other Traditions they were
born with impervious skin while still
others say their fur is so matted it
serves as pseudo armor all of these
conditions make stone giants resistant
to human weapons
some of the most aggressive versions of
these monsters have a particularly
grisly penchant for twisting the heads
off their human prey and legends of
bipedal beasts persist for centuries
even after European colonialism arrives
in the Americas 16th century Spanish
explorers and Mexican settlers told of
creatures called Los Vigilantes or
scuros or dark Watchers tall shadowy
beings that appear on the peaks of
California's Santa Lucia mountains
during Twilight watching over the land
and its inhabitants the lore of the
Watchers even made its way into a 1938
short story by John Steinbeck called
flight which describes the monsters as
menacing but relatively harmless figures
who wouldn't bother a visitor of the
forest if they stayed on the trail and
minded their own business
in 1847 Irish Canadian Adventurer and
artist Paul Kane recounted stories told
to him by the Chinook people about
skookums wild men who lived on the peaks
of Mount Saint Helens and engaged in
cannibalism Kane offered cash rewards
for anyone who could take him on a
journey to find the fabled skookums but
no such Trek ever took place and the
stories remained Legend
and perhaps the most infamous account
came from none other than former
president Teddy Roosevelt in his 1893
book The Wilderness Hunter Roosevelt
details a story told to him by a
grizzled old mountain man named Bauman
Bauman fearfully recounts his personal
experience with a foul-snelling bipedal
creature that ransacked his trapping
Camp left large prints stalked him and
ultimately killed one of his men by
snapping his neck while neither
Roosevelt nor Bauman name the creature
these descriptions have become Hallmarks
of Sasquatch lore namely the foul smell
and oversized Footprints this brings us
to the 20th century after the ape Canyon
incident of 1924 the next couple of
decades were relatively quiet in terms
of Sasquatch lore but advancements in
media starting in the mid-20th century
allowed for broader dissemination of
mysterious monster sightings the 1948
introduction of the Polaroid instant
camera alongside the development of
colored broadcast television and the
growing presence of TV sets in the
American household made it easier to
feed a growing appetite for Tabloid
Tails like when in 1958 a Bluff Creek
California logger named Jerry crew
discovered a series of oversized
human-like Footprints near a bulldozer
on his job site the 16 inches long
Footprints frightened and intrigued crew
and his fellow loggers when he returned
to town he brought his story to Andrew
genzoli a reporter for the Humboldt
times newspaper genzoli interviewed the
loggers and published an article about
the event complete with a photo of crew
holding a cast of one of the footprints
it wasn't this article that our monster
earned its new name Bigfoot when given
an English language-based name that was
both simple and evocative the monster
became a national sensation under the
new moniker older alleged sightings
including the 1924 Abe Canyon incident
became widely known and new encounters
were reported via the emerging mass
media network of American TV newspapers
and radio less than 10 years later in
1967 another new technology home movie
cameras gave rise to the most famous
piece of documented Bigfoot lore that
exists to date the one virtually
everyone has seen or seen spoofed the
Patterson gimlin film
shot on October 20th 1967 in Bluff Creek
California by two friends and Bigfoot
enthusiasts the film clip captures what
appears to be a large bipedal creature
trudging along a wooded Hillside in
broad daylight for almost a minute to
this day it Remains the most iconic and
controversial piece of evidence of the
existence of Sasquatch it doesn't take a
film forensics expert to see that the
Patterson gimlin film could easily be
replicated by any small group of people
with a camera and a bit of costuming
know-how while there have been
confessions and recently even AI
evidence that the footage does not
depict a mysterious monster for many it
still stands as evidence of Bigfoot's
existence some other familiar sightings
have been much more reliably debunked in
1982 a retired lager in his 80s rant
Mullins admitted to having tormented a
small group of gold prospectors in ape
Canyon when he was a young man he said
that he and his uncle had thrown stones
at their cabin from a rocky Overlook in
a playful attempt to scare hear them
then later having heard that the
prospector's tale about fearsome eight
men made national news Mullins claims to
have perpetrated several other Sasquatch
hoaxes in the region in the years that
followed in 2002 the family of Ray
Wallace a deceased co-worker of our
footprint finding logger friend Jerry
crew revealed that they had found a
collection of large carved wooden feet
stored in his basement which Wallace had
purportedly used to make the infamous
Footprints in Bluff Creek back in 1958
meaning even the origins of Bigfoot's
name was the result of a
well-perpetrated hoax
and yet despite all the evidence against
its existence Sasquatch remains firmly
fixed in our cultural psyche to this day
why and why does it seem that the public
perception of the monster has shifted
over time from friendly to fearsome and
back to Friendly again
many films portray Sasquatch as a
fearsome monster like The Legend of
Boggy Creek the much maligned cry
Wilderness and the properly terrifying
2013 indie horror Willow Creek and the
image of Sasquatch as a terror has
inspired some gripping novels as well
like Devolution by Max Brooks and
Roanoke Ridge by JJ Dupuis but the
version of Sasquatch many are most
familiar with today is much more benign
and friendly it's the one that we see as
a mascot for sports teams or as a
spokesperson for snack foods or beer or
a playful character appearing in video
games we might owe this return to a
somewhat softer image of saswatch to the
1987 film Harry and the Hendersons which
imagine the monster as a benevolent and
lovable creature of the woods whose
existence is threatened by human
encroachment this iteration of Sasquatch
coincides with growing public concerns
about environmental issues in the 1980s
the film's protagonist is a reluctant
Hunter Who falls in love with a titular
monster after hitting him with the
family's station wagon on a weekend
Excursion he and his family fight
against malevolent outside forces
hunting the Beast and are the only ones
who recognize Bigfoot as a precious and
vulnerable entity much like our natural
environment and Wilderness spaces who
needs saving in a way the lore of
Sasquatch has come full circle as our
modern perceptions of the monster are an
embodiment of respect for Our Mysterious
natural surroundings much like the
earliest lore of Sasquatch from the
indigenous cultures of North America
debunked sightings hoaxes and an often
cartoonish representation in pop culture
and yet the legend of Sasquatch still
has fervent Believers why is that
ecologist Robert Pyle contends that
there seems to be a general human need
to create folklore about Larger than
Life creatures with names usually
translating to something along the lines
of wild man or hairy man he writes that
these mythical creatures represent a
symbolic link to the Untamed Wilderness
that surrounds us a connection to our
world that modern society has largely
lost it also wasn't so long ago that our
ancestors were evolved to walk upright
using folklore particularly monsters
becomes a way to Outsource or displace
our Primal fears of the unknown World
our unknown past and our unknown future
we are scared of these creatures that
are not human but act human and look
more like us at our ancestors than we
may want to admit Perhaps it is no
coincidence that the ancient lore of
Sasquatch evolved and endured right
alongside the last century and a half of
North American industrialization and
modernization from our fears of the
unknown American frontier to our modern
anxieties about Humanity's effects on
our fragile environment whether
Sasquatch is a malevolent monster or a
misunderstood Beast just trying to
protect his realm one thing seems clear
the lore is likely to be around for a
long time to come reminding us to keep
an eye on the big footprints that we
leave behind as we move through this
world
before you go I want to talk about death
no not monstrous death but death death
or rather I want to tell you about a new
series on PBS voices called dead and
buried it's a show that explores
cultural perspectives and taboos
surrounding death and invites you to
reconsider how you think about the
inevitable we've got a link down below
tell them monstrum senya in the how
cuella language
should we do that again I think we
should just do that again for posterity